У цій лікарні у Бонні лікують двох пацієнток з коронавірусом з Італії.
Одній з них близько 50 років, а іншій вже під 70,
обох доставили з Бергамо в критичному стані.
Нині вони перебувають у відділенні інтенсивної терапії
під постійним наглядом медперсоналу.
Обом потрібна регулярна вентиляція легенів.
Як у багатьох випадках інтенсивної терапії, ще не зрозуміло,
чи зможемо добитися вдалого підсумка,
але ми боремося за їхні життя.
Рішення про прийом хворих з Італії ухвалювалося
на рівні федеральної землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія.
Тут не лише найбільша в Німеччині кількість випадків
зараження коронавірусом –вже понад 15 тисяч,
але й багато добре устаткованих лікарень.
Одна з них – якраз Університетська клініка в Бонні.
Це велика університетська лікарня на 1300 ліжкомісць,
з них 120 – ліжкомісця у відділеннях інтенсивної терапії,
устатковані апаратами штучної вентиляції легенів.
Якщо ситуація стане зовсім критичною, ми готові обладнати
додатково 50 ліжкомісць у відділеннях інтенсивної терапії.
Пацієнтів з Бергамо доставили в аеропорт Кельна минулої суботи
на борту бундесверівського аеробуса.
Такі далекомагістральні літаки використовуються
для доставки важкохворих пацієнтів.
Під час польоту ми повинні дбати про те, щоб пацієнти залишалися в стабільному стані.
Переліт - це додатковий стрес для пацієнтів,
тому ми маємо зробити все можливе,
аби стан їхнього здоров'я
не погіршився під час польоту.
Поки федеральна земля Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
прийняла 14 хворих з коронавірусом з-за кордону -
десятьох з Італії та чотирьох з Франції.
Двох італійців помістили в Університетську клініку в Кельні.
Їхній стан лікарі оцінюють як стабільний.
Тут, як і в Боннській лікарні – близько 120 ліжкомісць у відділенні інтенсивної терапії.
Зайняті з них поки одиниці, розповідає керівник відділення
внутрішньої медицини Маттіас Коханек.
Але чи не пізно Німеччина вирішила
допомагати італійцям?
Я вважаю, що кожен пацієнт, якому ми можемо допомогти, - це врятоване життя.
Тож, ніколи не можна казати, що вже надто пізно.
У нас так багато місця, і я радий, що ми можемо допомогти людям.
Але цілком можливо, що через 3-4 тижні
ми самі опинимося у схожій ситуації,
і я буду радий, якщо ми отримаємо аналогічні пропозиції від закордонних клінік.
Маттіас Коханек сам обстежує пацієнтів з Італії.
Лікування спеціально від коронавірусу ще не розробили,
тому лікарі у Кельні користуються медикаментами, які лікують схожі захворювання.
Наразі лікування таке саме, як і при гострому респіраторному синдромі.
Це не так вже сильно відрізняється від лікування
у випадку інших серйозних вірусних захворювань -
таких, як грип, свинячий грип і так далі.
Важливо, аби ми зупинили поширення,
для цього ухвалюється багато заходів,
частину з яких ми тестуємо тут, у рамках досліджень на базі клініки.
Окрім Північного Рейну-Вестфалії
пацієнтів з інших країн
прийняли Саксонія, Баден-Вюртемберг та Рейнланд-Пфальц.
Офіційний представник німецького МЗС повідомив минулого тижня,
що Німеччина готова прийняти загалом
агалом понад 120 пацієнтів з коронавірусом з Італії та Франції.